version is her new press secretary so
stephanie has been with me from the
beginning as most of you know and then
over the last couple years she's worked
for the first lady done a fantastic job
the first lady who loves her I think
she's been you know just incredible is
very talented and I have so many people
who do you like a lot of people wanted
to jump you know a lot of people wanted
to do it and I'd ask people who do you
like and so many people said Stephanie
and she's here she knows everybody she
actually gets along with the media very
well as you know a lot of the folks in
the media liked her very much and I
think she's gonna be fantastic I think
she's gonna do a great job so I offered
her the job this morning and she
accepted and the first lady is very
happy for her it's a big job it's a very
big job but we think Stephanie's going
to do a fantastic job and Hogan's going
to be with her Hogan was one of the
people that recommended it here's Hogan
he recommended her very strongly I said
Hogan who do you think he said Stephanie
worship
[Music]